and the last tune-up perhaps for zach
davies as he gets ready for the post
season i think he would be starting game
three if there is a game three it's a
swing and a miss so that's strike three
for fletcher first strikeout for zach
davies it's a change up right down the
middle cannot stay back great arm action
and that's exactly what zach davies
needs to do so two down two on and
albert pujols coming up 2-2 pitch coming
albert's way here with two down two on
and he reaches out it's a pop fly tatis
junior on the short line and left to
make the catch it ends the first inning
first and third with nobody out manny
machado coming up tatisco's at first
machado swings and misses throw down and
tatis has got himself stolen base base
is filled with padres and here's eric
hosmer
fly ball sent to left field justin upton
back a few steps
shaya the track will make the catch
tagging third is grisham he will score
and the padres take a one-nothing lead
as sac fly for eric cosmo
will be the batter
stassi skies went out toward left center
field hit well and that one's going to
get out of here
big fly for max dassey ties it up at one
a long way out for
max stassi sixth home run now the seas
with 18 rbis next to velocity of 108
miles per hour off the bat for max
dassey entertaining us with that
comes manny machado with the bases
filled with padres well this is exactly
what you wanted all season long
[Applause]
ball back to the mouth griffin bobbles
it they throw it home they get the relay
set first base and they turn a double
play two down ground ball exactly what
you want
ground ball comebacker one two three
double plays two down trout at first
anthony rendon one for two
this is down to third and machado he'll
go to second base for the fourth shot
there
a two out walk means nothing you didn't
want to mess with trout smart pitcher
this zach davies a man left middle of
the fifth andres have been held to two
hits so far as they bat with one out
here in the fifth colonel worth of first
base two two
and down goes bishop two down
tight slider downward tilt on that
slider for kenny fernando tatis junior's
been on board twice in the single little
one
emergency hack there by fernando tatis
jr
we'll head to the sixth inning so
canning ends up striking out the side
he's have a runner in scoring position
stassey with a couple of hits a home run
and a single
skies this one out to center field
grisham's going back on it onto the
track near the wall and that is gone
big fly for max stassi multi-homer game
and the angels have taken the lead it's
3-1
maximus entertaining us again with
another home run seven home runs now on
the season for
max stassi osmer with the sac fly back
in the first producing
the padres only run
got him but he's had a couple swings
like that against him that was a
change-up i mean just put the uh
fernando tatis junior and eric hosmer
swings yes oh my that's a new
career-high strikeouts tommy fam who has
struck out twice looking trying to
finish off the sixth inning 3-2
got him looking down goes fam a 10
strikeout night for griffith cannon
painted a fastball 93. two on one away
albert pujol standing in look for three
in this one he's popped out to short
flat out to the warning track in right
last time up struck out swinging
he'll sky this one out toward left field
toward the corner hit pretty well
heading over there is fam and he'll make
the catch in fair territory walsh will
head back to second drought back to
first i'll throw it off the bat that had
a chance getting out especially toward
that corner
two outs nola at first and jake cronin
worth the hitter
this is in the air to center
trout going back onto the warning track
to make the catch out there in deep left
center max stassi who has had quite a
game palmer in the second a solo shot
singled in the fourth and then hit a two
run home run to right center in the
sixth
it's out toward left center field fam is
not going to get there it's a four hit
game
trying to go to third base is taylor
ward to throw comes into second side
continues to entertain everyone tonight
with his first four hit game of his
career nobody out angel's threatening to
get some runs here
bounce the first base shot hosner comes
home and safe at home
i'm surprised hosmer came home on that
ball the angels would take it fielder's
choice in an rbi for rent he thought he
picks up his third run bound it in
grisham headed back out there with one
down to the inning and manny machado
coming up
on the ground down the third baseline's
a fair ball headed towards the left
field corner as grisham will come around
to score machado headed for second base
as upton will get it back in it's an rbi
double and it's now four to two angels
as the padres get a run back near the
bottom of the eighth
and it's first and third now with two
down in the inning
two two
and he gets moreland on the strikeout
bullhead to the ninth drought nobody on
and number nine hitter jake cronenworth
at the plate
swinging a miss john goes corona worth
light that baby up as the angels take
the opener of this two-game set by the
final of 4-2